let's talk about the Wagner group
secretive Russian mercenary shadowy
private security company that has ties
to the Kremlin group has a gruesome
reputation
the Wagner group has been around for
about 10 years
and its forces have shown up in all
sorts of places from Syria to Mali to
Mozambique what Wagner is doing is
essentially acting as a proxy for the
Russian government in different armed
conflicts
and recently they've been getting a lot
of attention because of what they're
doing in Ukraine Wagner went for being
this small kind of special forces like
mercenary group in Africa to sort of
large cannon fodder on the fields of
Ukraine so what do we actually know
about the Wagner group what it does
where it operates and who's behind it
foreign
group is secretive and hard to Define
but basically they get paid to send
their armed Personnel to different
countries you could say that makes them
mercenaries but that word has a legal
definition that doesn't always fit with
what they do they're also often
described as a PMC a private military
company but that doesn't quite fit
either because Wagner isn't just one
company it's better thought of as a
loose network of companies financial
intermediaries that are all linked
together in as opaque away as possible
so as to make it difficult to understand
what their financial and organizational
links are and to make it very difficult
to hold them accountable for their
actions
now the group first appeared in 2014
when Russia illegally annexed Crimea and
sided with pro-russian separatists in
eastern Ukraine footage of masked
soldiers and unmarked uniforms started
cropping up people were calling them
little green men and at least some of
them were linked to the Wagner group
now the group's name is in reference to
the German composer Richard Wagner who
was Hitler's favorite and Wagner was
apparently the battlefield call sign
used by a guy named Dimitri utkin who
used to be a special forces officer in
the Russian military he's often been
talked about as the group's founder and
is reportedly still involved the demand
you really need to know about is yevgeny
progosian a Russian oligarch for years
he denied having any links to the Wagner
group but recently that changed
in late 2022 he came out of the Shadows
there are now several videos of pagosian
at work with his forces on the ground
and trying to sign up new recruits
foreign
pagosian also published this statement
claiming that he founded the group back
in 2014. he officially registered the
company as a Consulting business and
opened up a flashy new headquarters in
St Petersburg which is significant not
only for being Wagner's first official
headquarters first formal existence on
paper and on property but also for the
fact that it is located on Russian soil
where pmcs are technically illegal
um
now pagosian's relationship with Putin
goes back to the 1990s they're from the
same city of Saint Petersburg where
pagosian went from selling hot dogs to
owning several restaurants
and Putin was a regular customer after
becoming president he brought along some
pretty well-known dignitaries and
pregosian picked up the nickname of
Putin's chef
soon he was scoring some pretty
lucrative catering contracts including
for the Russian military over the years
he's become super rich politically
influential and has built up a media
Empire too
okay now back to the Wagner group itself
since they first popped up in Ukraine in
2014 the Wagner group has been active in
at least eight other countries they're
the ones that we know of for sure anyway
so for example in Syria they're
supporting the forces of President
Bashar al-assad the Russian armies there
too while in Venezuela another Russian
Ally Wagner went in in 2019 as a
protection Force for president Nicolas
Maduro who was facing huge protests and
on the African continent well that's
where the Wagner group has really honed
its business model we've seen this be a
targeted effort against countries with
weak governance ongoing security
challenges often times an authoritarian
or military government and Rich natural
resources that they can exploit as part
of that deal often through mining
concessions diamond mines gold mines oil
stuff like that and so that's the
business model in exchange for
extractive industry they will provide
muscle and protection but it's more than
that because there are political
interests mixed in there too and that's
because of the Wagner group's connection
to the Russian government the thing with
Wagner is is part of Russia's strategy
in terms of how to build these
influences in African continent
and trying to cut themselves as an
alternative to the West especially in
contexts where Western lead Solutions
are filled the political relationship
supports the security relationship the
security relationship forces a political
relationship
Central African Republic for example in
2017 the president fausten Arkansas to
Adera turned to Russia for help to fight
various Rebel groups Russia sent weapons
and Military instructors and Wagner went
into along with those formal Russian
deployments many of the so-called
trainers that went in and additional
forces that would go in over time were
actually Wagner troops then in 2018 a
company linked to burgosian was granted
diamond and gold mining licenses and
over time the Wagner group has become
even more prominent in the car before
the last election
is
escorting the president as it goes
around company for before the elections
right so that is as Blitz on as it gets
we really see them deeply integrated
into the running of
more or less the country there have been
some reports from individuals on the
ground that when a person reaches out to
more or less the local equivalent of
9-1-1 what they get on the other end is
Wagner Personnel the UN believes there
are now several thousand Wagner
operatives in the car and says that
along with other forces they've been
committing human rights abuses including
arbitrary detention torture
disappearances and summary execution and
we see this kind of thing in other
places where Wagner is operating too
wherever they go there's a trail of
Human Rights abuse and violations like
in Mali where the Wagner group has been
active since 2021.
in the town of Mora Wagner forces and
mali's Military are accused of having
executed several hundred people
what we've seen in in Mali is that
Wagner was being deployed to deal with
Insurgency so it was being deployed as a
in essence a counter-terrorism
response no that in itself is not
problematic but the problem is that an
entire population
is being targeted and tagged as you know
terrorists now the likelihood of any
kind of accountability when it comes to
the Wagner group's activities is next to
zero is especially when government
forces are also involved local forces
are complicit or participating alongside
wagon
it's very difficult
to focus some kind of accountability
even if we did have good International
laws against mercenaries who's going to
go into Mali and arrest all those
mercenaries or Libya and arrest all
those not the United Nations not NATO
nobody's gonna do it okay so that's a
snapshot of how Wagner has been
operating around the world but now let's
look at Ukraine because they're being
used there in a very different way on a
different scale and Wagner has been
making a difference on the Russian side
for example it was Wagner not the
Russian army that made the first
significant Russian gain in months when
they captured the town of solidar back
in January we see Wagner operating more
or less as a military unit an informal
unit of the Russian military and we
particularly see them taking the lead in
areas such as Bachman where they've
essentially turned their operations just
into cannon fodder they're fighting to
hold the front lines and to take
territory there
but that takes a lot of men we're
talking tens of thousands and the U.S
estimates that ninety percent of them
are Russian convicts recruited from
prisons who've been promised Freedom if
they served six months on the
battlefield although pagosian says he's
now stopped recruiting prisoners in not
about
Broad
Terry strategy it is throwing bodies at
a problem and there are absolutely
horrific stories of how these soldiers
are being used by the Wagner group
foreign
now this new overt way that Wagner is
operating in Ukraine introduces some new
challenges for the group and for the
Russian government who've always denied
they exist officially at least and this
is one of the main reasons why Wagner's
been so useful to Russia they were
really the kremlin's weapon of choice
because they gave great plausible
deniability to the Kremlin in case
things went badly some new rivalries
have opened up too especially between
pregosian and Russia's top military
leaders recently he accused them of
treason for not supplying his men with
enough ammunition and it's got a lot of
people talking about what pergosian's
strategy might be
[Music]
Premiere I
cons of political power and influence
are growing and I think that he is using
the opportunity of the Ukraine war and
the Wagner group's role in the fighting
to really Propel himself forward and to
pursue those Ambitions pagosian imagines
himself as sitting at the right hand of
the Czar Tsar Putin and this is created
rivalries within the siloviki within the
Russian military establishment because
this Outsider is now getting the
attention of Putin but I think pregosian
stock is only as good as his delivery of
victories
we actually put together a whole episode
about Vladimir Putin explaining his rise
to power and his worldview you can check
it out here
[Music]